but our view was the benefits that this
is likely to lead to in terms of
reducing uh impacts in education
outweighed those negative errors
so overall our assessment is combining
the marginal but
assessed benefit that jcvi made at
individual level
taking on board additionally the issues
around education
our view was the benefit exceeded the
risk to a sufficient degree that we are
recommending to our ministers in all
four nations
that they make a universal offer and i
want to stress the word offer
of vaccination to children
12 to 15 in addition to the ones that
have already been given it
so that is our current
advice to ministers and it is now with
them
to decide in each of the four nations uh
how they wish to respond just want to
add one additional thing and then i'd
like to ask dr rain and professor lim to
add from their sides and then turned to
my cmo colleagues
and that is that
we are really clear that it is very
important that um
this balanced decision of how the
benefits exceed the risks but the the
fact that these are closer than they are
in for example people in their 50s 60s
70s
are communicated
fairly and properly
to children young people and their
parents so that they can make a
considered decision that's very much
something we think is important and that
children young people and their parents
are supported in the decisions they make
and there is no stigmatization of people
either for accepting or not accepting
vaccination we do think this is really
critical and our colleagues in general
practice and in pediatrics and child
health will work with colleagues in
public health to try and help make sure
that that
balance of understanding is presented in
a an appropriate way that actually makes
sense and is comprehensible by people at
different ages
about what's going on so that is uh our
overall advice but that important rider
at the end
so i'd like to turn if i may to dr rain
just add some comments from mhra's point
of view
well thank you cmo and good afternoon as
the independent regulator for the uk for
medicines and vaccines we have
rigorously reviewed all the data on
safety quality and effectiveness of
pfizer and moderna for use in young
people and children 12 to 15 years old
and this data was also reviewed by the
commission on human medicines its expert
advisory group on vaccine benefit risk
and the pediatric medicines expert
advisory group all leading experts in
their field
over 2000 children were studied 2000 age
12 to 15 in the trials immunogenicity
studies
showed similar neutralizing antibody
levels in adolescents as in young adults
and these results together with the
clinical trial data showed a very high
level of short-term efficacy consistent
with that seen in adults and in fact
there was evidence that the vaccine
provides protection even before dose two
these are extremely positive results
we've continued our job with ongoing
proactive monitoring of safety and i'd
like to say a few words about suspected
side effects you will have seen our adr
report which comes out every week with
the latest data but there has been a
particular interest in reports of heart
inflammation myocarditis and
pericarditis these both happen very
rarely in the
general population and our job is to
continually review the balance of what
we observe against what we expect to see
we've undertaken a very thorough review
both of the uk and the international
reports there's a consistent pattern
there are slightly more
often frequently do we see cases in
young males and after the second dose
but overall the conclusion of our expert
advisors is that these are mild cases
individuals usually recover within a
short period of time with standard
treatment and our advice remains that
the benefits outweigh the risks of
getting vaccinated and this includes
those age 12 to 15.
thank you cmo thank you dr um professor
lim
thank you and thank you for this chance
to explain where we're at
you will remember that it was not that
long ago that we provided advice from
jcbi regarding
12 to 15 year olds and in particular
regarding 12 to 15 years who don't have
underlying health conditions that put
them at risk
we concluded that there was overall
marginal benefit from vaccination
we felt that that marginal benefit was
not sufficient to advise universal offer
or vaccination
i also want to stress today that jcbi
obviously recognizes the large impact
that the pandemic has had on our
children
and this is not simply because of direct
infection or illness on children but
because of the many other factors
involved in the pandemic not least
social isolation
missing school and being off school has
had a particularly profound impact on
our children
this is an impact not just on
educational attainment but also on
mental health and all the other learning
that comes from socially interacting
with our peers and colleagues and in
teachers as well
so an important question that arises
is to ask to what degree does
vaccination reduce
time off school for our children
the answer to that question is
influenced by many things
and it's particularly influenced by the
policies around school isolation
measures
school closures and school infection
control measures just as examples
those things are outside the remit of
jcvi
but they are important
and it was because of that that when we
gave our advice to ministers we
highlighted to ministers that there are
other factors that are worth considering
and suggested to ministers that they
could if they wish to
ask the cmos to assess the impact of
vaccination on these other factors
therefore today
the fact that the cmos have done this
assessment and this review is good news
for everybody because then
the wider impacts of vaccination have
been examined and i want to stress that
this by no means means that there is any
conflict between the advice provided by
jcvi
and the advice and decision that's been
provided by the cmos to the secretary of
state